newsreels is an app that lets you see
every side of every news story compare
sources for any news story use your
reels feed to stay caught up on Daily
News and absorb everything quickly
through the summarized bullet points
newsreels keeps you informed and gives
you a neutral balance perspective click
the link below
hey I'm going to show you some stunning
video
of Republican senator Lindsey Graham
being brutally booed for saying you
should think about getting that vaccine
this happened to Trump and I'll remind
you of that Daily Beast reporting
Republicans shout Down Lindsey Graham
for pushing the vaccine
uh this is from our friend will summer
who's been a guest on the program before
who writes Senator Lindsey Graham was
booed by Republican activist Saturday
after he suggested they should consider
taking the coronavirus vaccine making
him the latest prominent Republican to
face a backlash from the party's
Grassroots over the vaccine speaking at
a County Republican event in Summerville
South Carolina
Graham said he received the vaccine and
encouraged audience members to take it
as well
Graham cited statistics showing most
patients are unvaccinated and the crowd
only got more Angry let's look at this
video we're going to look at the Trump
video as well here's Lindsay and listen
to the crowd
if you haven't had the vaccine you want
to think about getting it because I said
you're my age
no they say
they don't even want to think it's
actually quite quite stunning they're
told just think about it they don't even
want to do that it's actually emblematic
of this Republican party I'm glad I got
it 92 of the people in the hospitals in
South Carolina unvaccinated
foreign
they don't believe him
they they at least claim not to believe
him he says most people in the hospital
are in fact no no
I'm with you um let's don't mandate it
right I'm with you that is probably
unconstitutional but I am not going to
legitimize what I think is the truth the
truth is
60 days you got to stop it now okay so
this guy's screaming
this gentleman although I don't really
know if he's a gentleman this guy says
he's going to lose his job in 60 days if
he doesn't get vaccinated he wants
Lindsay to stop it
okay I'm a veteran too how many of you
have taken measles shots
[Applause]
so Lindsay tries another approach how
many of you have been vaccinated against
measles and the crowd is prepared
they're prepared they say well but
that's not the same military in the
military they can say you got to get
vaccinated I think that's a dumb idea
you know why we should be driving people
away from serving like if you're a
health care worker yeah we have plenty
of soldiers and you don't want to get
vaccinated
why do you want to get people equipped
being nurses
I trust you to make a decision good for
you so are you against the vaccine no
the half the crowd says yes half the
crowd says no
that's why
uh you're gonna have to get somebody
yeah so that guy is completely unhinged
so um there's Looney Lindsay uh getting
but he's trying to not be loony he's
trying to be sensible Lindsay and it
doesn't go well this is what happens
when the monster you created turns
against you here's a reminder of when it
happened to Trump this was at a rally
not long ago remember this guy's this
was wild
three days less than nine months and
it's great and you know what I believe
totally in your freedoms I do you got to
do what you have to do
[Applause]
I did it it's good take the vaccines but
you go that's okay that's all right you
got your freedoms
but I happen to take the vaccine if it
doesn't work you'll be the first to know
okay I'll call up Alabama say hey you
know what
but it is working
but uh you do they do not like it you
built this monster and now it is biting
the owner's head off the Creator's head
off
um folks this is increasingly a
republican virus you know remember that
image from earlier this week uh the last
100 coveted deaths have mostly been in
trumplandia I showed you this earlier in
the week you look at a map of the last
hundred thousand kova deaths it looks
like the map of where they voted for
Trump most heavily
um the the strategy the approach here
seems to be
owning the Liberals by getting coveted
and dying or something like that they
believe they're proving a point in this
way and at this point people like
Lindsey Graham who's cuckoo but slightly
less cuckoo than some of the others he
seems to realize we gain Nothing by not
getting vaccinated just our voters die
at a greater rate than their voters and
that's probably not good for elections
it's probably not good for economies
it's not good for anything it has become
a bizarre it I mean can is it a pyric
victory
in the sense that they don't get
vaccinated but then some of them die and
it's a win but you're sustaining a loss
and that people are dying I don't know
what to call it maybe just dumb maybe we
don't need to go uh and try to be more
sophisticated than what it calls for
maybe it's just dumb and bad a bad idea
uh but they turned on on Lindsay just
like they did on Donald Trump reminder
Tuesday October 19 we're doing a live
viewer Town Hall
um everybody can participate it will be
streamed live on the new YouTube channel
that's the Pacman live YouTube channel
you can find it at youtube.com
Pacman live or davidpackman.com
pacmanlive 6 p.m Eastern Tuesday October
19th everybody's welcome to call in we
will take call after call and members
will get priority so why not sign up at
joinpakman.com